STORM, SUPERSTORM, DROURGHT,
WILDFIRE, HURRICANE CAN BE DEALT
WITH.
LAST YEAR ALONE THE UNITED
STATES, AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THESE KIND OF EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS, LOST $99 BILLION IN THE
UNITED STATES ALONE IN DAMAGE.
AFTER HURRICANE IDA, I SEE THE
DISTINGUISHED GOVERNOR FROM
LOUISIANA IS OVER THERE.
I SAW HIM STAND UP.
I WENT DOWN TO SEE HIM.
WE WENT THROUGH AND SAW ALL THE
DAMAGE THERE.
THEY HAD 179-MILE-AN-HOUR WINDS
AT TOP SPEED IN LOUISIANA.
BUT THEN I HEADED ON UP TO NEW
YORK, CHUCK, UP IN YOUR AREA,
QUEENS AND NEW JERSEY.
MORE PEOPLE DIED THERE THAN IN
THE HURRICANE.
MORE PEOPLE DIED IN THE
FLOODING.
RECORD WILDFIRES RAGED AND
WENT -- WENT TO IDAHO AND
CALIFORNIA AND SAW IT.
MORE LAND IS BURNED TO THE
GROUND THAN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
NEW JERSEY OUT WEST.
FOLKS, WALK THE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND LOOK THE PEOPLE IN THE EYE
IN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES, AS MANY
OF YOU HAVE, AND YOU'LL SEE THE
DESPAIR AND THE HEARTACHE.
SO MANY OF YOU UNDERSTAND YOU
ARE LIVING THROUGH IT.
THIS LAW BUILDS BACK OUR
BRIDGES, OUR WATER SYSTEMS, OUR
POWER LINES, OUR LEVEES.
BETTER AND STRONGER.
SO FEW AMERICANS WILL BE FLOODED
OUT OF THEIR HOMES AND LOSE
POWER, LOSE DAYS AND WEEKS.
FOLKS, THIS BIPARTISAN LAW FOR
THE FIRST TIME EVER CREATES A
TRUE NATIONAL NETWORK OF
CHARGING STATIONS FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
OVER 500,000 SO YOU CAN CHARGE
YOUR CAR HERE AND DRIVE ALL THE
WAY TO CALIFORNIA NOT WORRYING
ABOUT HAVING TO FIND PLACES TO
CHARGE.
CREATING THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
THOUSANDS.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR AMERICANS TO GET
OFF THE SIDELINES AND INTO THE
GAME OF MANUFACTURING, SOLAR
PANELS, WIND TURBINES, BATTERIES
TO STORE ENERGY AND POWER,
ELECTRIC VEHICLES, INCLUDING
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES, WHICH
WILL MEAN MILLIONS OF CHILDREN
WILL NO LONGER INHALE THE
DANGEROUSDIESEL FUMES THAT COME
OUT OF THE BUSES.
AND REWARD COMPANIES FOR PAYING
GOOD WAGES AND FOR BUYING
AMERICAN SOURCING THEIR PRODUCTS
HERE IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
IT'S GOING TO HELP THE UNITED
STATES EXPLORE CLEAN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES TO THE WORLD.
CREATING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
MORE JOBS.
THERE'S SO MUCH MORE IN THE LAW,
BUT MOST OF ALL, IT DOES
SOMETHING TRULY HISTORIC.
I RAN FOR PRESIDENT BELIEVING IT
WAS TIME TO REBUILD THE BACKBONE
OF THIS NATION WHICH I
CHARACTERIZE AS WORKING PEOPLE
IN THE MIDDLE CLASS.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO BUILT THE
COUNTRY.
AND TO REBUILD THE ECONOMY FROM
THE BOTTOM UP AND THE MIDDLE
OUT, THIS LAW DELIVERS ON THAT
LONG OVERDUE PROMISE IN MY VIEW.
IT CREATES BETTER JOBS FOR
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS AND NO
ONE, NO ONE AARONING INGEARNING
$400,000 A YEAR WILL PAY A
SINGLE PENNY IN FEDERAL TAXES
BECAUSE OF IT.
AND IT DOES NOT INCLUDE, AS WE
DID THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE A SINGLE PENNY IN GAS
TAX WHICH I REJECTED BECAUSE
PEOPLE UNDER $400,000 AREN'T
PAYING IT.
IT LEAVES NO ONE BEHIND AND IT
MARKS AN INFLECTION POINT THAT
WE FACE AS A NATION.
FOR MOST OF THE 20th CENTURY, WE
LED THE WORLD BY SIGNIFICANT
MARGIN BECAUSE WE INVESTED IN
OURSELVES.
BUT SOMEWHERE ALONG THE WAY WE
STOPPED INVESTING IN OURSELVES.
WE RISK LOSING OUR EDGE AS A
NATION AND CHINA AND THE REST OF
THE WORLD ARE CATCHING UP.
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE USED TO BE
RATED THE BEST IN THE WORLD.
NOW, ACCORDING TO THE WORLD
ECONOMIC FORUM WE RANK 13th IN
THE WORLD.
WELL, THAT'S ABOUT TO CHANGE.
THINGS ARE GOING TO TURN AROUND
IN A BIG WAY.
FOR EXAMPLE, BECAUSE OF THIS LAW
NEXT YEAR WILL BE THE FIRST YEAR
IN 20 YEARS AMERICAN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT WILL
GROW FASTER THAN CHINA'S.
ONCE AGAIN WE'LL HAVE THE BEST
ROADS, BRIDGES, PORTS AND
AIRPORTS OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
IT WILL LEAD THE WORLD INTO THE
21st CENTURY WITH MODERN CARS
AND TRUCKS AND TRANSIT SYSTEMS.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS BY
BUILDING AGAIN AND MOVING AGAIN.
FOLKS, TOO OFTEN IN WASHINGTON
THE REASON WE DIDN'T GET THINGS
DONE IS BECAUSE WE INSISTED ON
GETTING EVERYTHING WE WANT.
EVERYTHING.
WITH THIS LAW, WE FOCUS ON
GETTING THINGS DONE.
I RAN FOR PRESIDENT BECAUSE THE
ONLY WAY TO MOVE THIS COUNTRY
FORWARD WAS THROUGH COMPROMISE
AND CONSENSUS.
THAT'S HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS.
THAT'S AMERICAN DEMOBERACY.
AND I AM GOING TO BE SIGNING A
LAW THAT IS TRULY CONSEQUENTIAL
BECAUSE WE MADE OUR DEMOCRACY
DELIVER FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE COMPROMISED.
WE REACHED A CONSENSUS.
THAT'S NECESSARY.
AND NOW OUR FOCUS MOVES TO
IMPLEMENTING AN INFRASTRUCTURE
LAW THAT'S GOING TO SPEED AND
WITH DISCIPLINE.
I HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
DOING THAT.
WHEN I WAS VICE PRESIDENT, I WAS
GIVEN RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OVERSEEING AND IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOVERY ACT FOR NEARLY $900
BILLION EMERGENCY PACKAGE.
I'M PROUD TO SEE WHEN WE
FINISHED IMPLEMENTING THAT
RECOVERY ACT IT WAS DETERMINED
THERE HAD BEEN LESS THAN 0.2%
WASTE, FRAUD OR ABUSE.
AND I WAS -- AND IT WAS HOW I
LEARNED AND EARNED THE NICKNAME
SHERIFF JOE FROM PRESIDENT OBAMA
BECAUSE I MADE IT A POINT, EVERY
SINGLE DAY FOR WELL OVER A YEAR
TO STAY ON TOP OF HOW THE MONEY
WAS BEING USED.
I SPOKE WITH OVER 160 MAYORS,
TWO, THREE TIMES SOMETIMES, AND
I SPOKE WITH COUNTY EXECUTIVES
AND EVERY GOVERNOR, SAVE ONE.
I WON'T MENTION THAT.
SAVE ONE.
SHE CAN SEE ALASKA FROM HER
PORCH.
MONITOR WHAT WE'RE DOING.
JUST HOW IT WAS BEING DONE.
AND ONE OF THE MOST EFFICIENT
IMPLEMENTATIONS OF A PROGRAM IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
WE OWE IT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO DO THE SAME THING AGAIN AND
TO MAKE SURE EVERY PENNY IS
SPENT WHERE IT'S SUPPOSED TO GO
IN A TIMELY FASHION.
I'VE ASKED THE FORMER MAYOR OF
NEW ORLEANS AND FORMER
LIEUTENANT OF LOUISIANA, MITCH
LANDRIEU TO OVERSEE THIS
RESPONSIBILITY.
HE'LL HAVE FULL ACCESS TO EVERY
TOOL OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO GET IT DONE.
AND WE HAVE THE HIGH OBLIGATION
AND RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THIS MONEY IS USED WISELY AND
USED WELL.
FOLKS, I HAVE BEEN LOOKING
FORWARD TO THIS DAY FOR A LONG
TIME LIKE ALL MY COLLEAGUES.
TOMORROW, I'LL BE TRAVELING TO
NEW HAMPSHIRE TO VISIT A BRIDGE
THAT IS STRUCTURALLY NOT SAFE.
LIKE THOUSANDS OF BRIDGES ACROSS
AMERICA.
THAT'S WHAT THIS LAW IS ALL
ABOUT.
KEEPING COMMUNITIES SAFER, MORE
EFFICIENT.
ON WEDNESDAY I'LL BE IN DETROIT
TO MEET WITH UAW WORKERS
BUILDING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
VEHICLES.
AND THAT'S JUST THE BEGINNING.
WE'RE ALSO SEEING -- YOU'LL BE
SEEING ME AND VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS, JILL AND DOUG, CABINET
OFFICIALS HITTING THE ROAD TO
HELP YOU UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS
GOING TO TRANSFORM YOUR LIVES
FOR THE BETTER.
AND FOLKS, WHEN YOU SEE THOSE
PROJECTS STARTING IN YOUR
HOMETOWNS, I WANT YOU TO FEEL
WHAT I FEEL.
PRIDE.
PRIDE IN WHAT WE CAN DO TOGETHER
AS THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
FOLKS, YOU KNOW, THE SAYING GOES
FOR MY PLAN TO BUILD BACK BETTER
FOR THE PEOPLE, GETTING FOLKS
BACK TO WORK AND REDUCING COST
OF THINGS LIKE CHILD CARE, ELDER
CARE, HOUSING, HEALTH CARE,
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND MEETING
THE MOMENT ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE HOUSE
WILL PASS THIS BILL AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PASS IT
IN THE SENATE.
AND THAT'S FULLY PAID FOR.
IT WILL REDUCE THE DEFICIT OVER
LONG-TERM ACCORDING TO LEADING
ECONOMISTS IN THE WORLD AND
AGAIN, NO ONE EARNING LESS THAN
$400,000 WILL PAY A SINGLE PENNY
MORE IN FEDERAL TAXES.
AND TOGETHER, TOGETHER WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, MILLIONS OF
LIVES WILL BE CHANGED FOR THE
BETTER.
FOLKS, LET ME CLOSE WITH THIS.
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY, WE'VE
EMERGED FROM CRISES BY INVESTING
IN OURSELVES.
DURING AND AFTER THE CIVIL WAR,
WE BUILT THE TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILWOOD, UNITING EAST AND WEST.
DURING THE COLD WAR WE BUILT THE
INTERSTATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
TRANSFORMING HOW AMERICA LIVED
THEIR LIVES.
AND NOW WE'RE EMERGING FROM
COVID-19 PANDEMIC AND WE'RE
BUILDING AN ECONOMY FOR THE 21st
CENTURY.
WHEN I MET WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
CHINA, WHOM I'M GOING TO BE
SPEAKING WITH TONIGHT, SEVERAL
YEARS AGO, HE ASKED ME, HE SAID,
COULD I DEFINE AMERICA.
AND I SAID ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S THE GOD'S TRUTH.
I SAID ABSOLUTELY.
I CAN DEFINE IT IN ONE WORD.
POSSIBILITIES.
THERE IS NO LIMIT TO WHAT OUR
PEOPLE THINK WE CAN DO.
AND THERE IS NO LIMIT TO WHAT
OUR NATION CAN DO.
AND THERE IS NO ONE THING THAT I
KNOW MORE THAN THIS.
IT'S NEVER, EVER BEEN A GOOD BET
TO BET AGAINST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
NEVER, NEVER, NEVER.
GIVEN HALF A CHANCE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE NEVER,
EVER, EVER LET THIS NATION DOWN.
AND IT'S OUR JOB TO GIVE OUR
PEOPLE THAT CHANCE.
IT'S OUR JOB TO COME TOGETHER
AND MAKE SURE WE REMAIN A NATION
OF POSSIBILITIES AS I LOOK OUT
ON THIS CROWD TODAY.
I SEE DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
NATIONAL LEADERS, LOCAL LEADERS,
ALL ELECTED OFFICIALS.
LABOR LEADERS, BUSINESS LEADERS,
MOST OF ALL, FELLOW AMERICANS.
I SEE AMERICA.
LET'S REMEMBER THIS DAY.
LET'S REMEMBER WE CAN COME
TOGETHER, MOST OF ALL, LET'S
REMEMBER WHAT WE'VE GOT DONE FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN WE DO
COME TOGETHER.
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT 50 YEARS
FROM NOW, HISTORIANS WILL LOOK
BACK AT THIS MOMENT AND SAY,
THAT'S THE MOMENT AMERICA BEGAN
TO WIN THE COMPETITION OF THE
21st CENTURY.
SO WITH CONFIDENCE, OPTIMISM,
WITH VISION AND FAITH IN EACH
OTHER, LET'S BELIEVE IN
POSSIBILITIES.
LET'S BELIEVE IN ONE ANOTHER.
AND LET'S BELIEVE IN AMERICA.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL, AND MAY GOD
PROTECT OUR TROOPS.
NOW LET ME SIGN THIS BIPARTISAN
BILL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
MY MASK.
FO
FOLKS, I'M GOING TO GET EACH OF
YOU A PEN.
BUT THERE'S 30 OF YOU.
I ONLY HAVE ONE PE